від ранку в Лаврі людно 29 березня УПЦ
яка донедавна називалася церквою
Московського патріархату має залишити
стіни святині сотні людей прийшли як
кажуть молитися за свою церкву
підтримати монахів та помилитися за мир
за те щоб все було добре щоб не було
ніяких розколів не було ніяких там я не
знаю
протидії
незаконних ну Дивіться Ну що ми будемо
дратися чи що
рукопашно Ні звичайно ми прийшли
помолитися якщо будуть виштовхувати
підемо служба минає спокійно Утім
атмосфера біля храму напружена А цей
привезли Томаса і почали битися один з
одним Хіба це правильно
це значить сила сатани якась розколола
суспільство що ми Отак ненавиділи один
одного прийшов подивитися як за сьогодні
реалізується Постанова міністерства
культури України Про виселення
представників рпц території
національного заповідника
києво-печерської лавра я побачив в
принципі я нічого нового купа фанатиків
які нічого не бачать окрім своїх вони не
бачать того що Онуфрій який очолює все
це якому вони цілують Руки є діючим
членом рпц синоду досі вони не бачать те
як благословляєшся зброя яка щоденна
вбиває наших людей пцу прийде сюди і
будуть сюди сидіти тут за нашим ну
побачите
монастир приймав споруди все одно тут в
будинках дерева росли а сюди монахи
прийшли відвалили Я взагалі людина
невіруюча Скажімо так ягностик але мені
дуже
Щоб наша держава могла захиститися сама
себе а на даний час от в вигляді оцього
Московського патріархату це
держава-агресор в нас тут перебуває Я з
Донбасу приїхав в мене син родився
24-24 августа
91-му році він Ровесник незалежности як
я не буду любити нашу Вітчизну А мене
хочуть колаборанти в російській попи
записували Де написано що я російський
поп в чому моя вина як довела
релігієзнавча експертиза держслужби з
етнополітики та свободи совісті УПЦ не
розірвала канонічні зв'язки з російською
православною церквою представники цієї
релігійної організації десять років
безоплатно користувалися приміщеннями та
майном Лаври нині вони не мають наміру
виселятися
треба молитися
наш захист насамперед це благання Бога
просити гріхи наші та зберегти нас
по-перше від ворожнечі державної подруга
від ворожнечі і народної настоятель
монастиря Павло Лебідь проти якого РНБО
запровадила санкції повідомив прихожанам
що його церква отримала листа від
києво-печерського заповідника у ньому
зазначено що виселення з Лаври
відбудеться 30 березня
я хочу вас достати різними всіх закон на
нашій стороні тому що по закону про
Конституції і по інших законах нас не
мають права
оскаржує розірвання з ними договору про
користування лаврою в суді тим не менш
Тиждень тому де ви зафільмувала ось такі
кадри з приміщень Лаври почали вивозити
ікони книги й особисті речі
священнослужителів у 2013 році за
дорученням Кабміну Микола Азарова
києво-печерський заповідник уклав
договір з УПЦ за цим договором так звана
нижня лавра прийшла у користування
церкви нині Цей договір розривається
підстава незаконні новобудови і добудови
такі як наприклад Ось ця брама у 2015
році є розібрали і побудували заново
позицію УПЦ цього приводу у розмові з ДВ
висловив речник цієї церкви митрополит
Климент він полягав аби у сюжеті деве
називала пцу церквою
константинопольського патріархату якщо
його церкву називатимуть УПЦ
Московського патріархату клімат
переконаний що розірвання договору з
його церквою на підставі закидів про
перебудову об'єкта спадщини Юнеско
незаконне мовляв з висновками експертної
комісії міністерства культури яка
фіксувала не дозволене будівництво
незнайомі наші юристи Звернулися до
Міністерства до інших відомств він з
вимогою оприлюднити результати свій
експертизи для того щоб нам ознайомитися
нам сказали що це неможливо тому що на
цю експертизу накладений гриф для
службового користування нам пропонують
повірити на слово всьому тому що заявляє
чиновники Ми віримо в Бога а не в
Міністерство культури у
києво-печерському заповіднику знали про
всі порушення і до 2013 року і після
кажуть інформували про них Міністерство
культури але нічого не могли вдіяти
ситуація така те що порушення зафі
сьогодні про них писали і давайте так
останні 20 років про порушення в
києво-печерській Лаврі писали і сусід
наказали чому нічого не робиться зараз
зробили пише А чому лише зараз збили
добре а якщо б ми зараз зробили через 10
років щось змінилося би Утім питання не
лише в новобудовах міністр культури
Олександр Ткаченко натякав що
принциповим є знаходження в Лаврі під
санкційних осіб це зокрема намісник
Лаври Павло Лебідь і керуючий справами
УПЦ Антоній паканич релігія знавець Ігор
Козловський додає на тлі війни у
суспільства з'явилося чимало питань до
УПЦ а філійованої з рпц наприклад
стосовно колаборантів серед священиків і
зв’язків з Росією стосовно тих же самих
санкцій і знову ж таки так якщо у вас є
такі особи ну церква повинна хоча б
розпочати там розслідування Чому держава
таких
зробили такими
персонами які підпадають під санкції але
ж церква знову ж таки нічого не зробила
Тобто ми не бачимо тих зрушень які
очікує і суспільства і держави тому
держава і зрозуміла ставить питання вже
в просторі правовому ключове питання
нині що буде з лаврою далі низка
експертів певні що процес виселення УПЦ
звідти триватиме довго церква буде
відстоювати свої права можливо через
судові інстанції ми ж розуміємо що
просто так виселяти людей Ніхто ж не
буде не будуть Там ми ж не Росія ми не
будемо створювати та конфліктні ситуації
да будуть судові процеси суд буде
виносити певні рішення як довго це буде
продовжуватися ну важко сказати чи
діятиме в стінах Лаври чоловічий
монастир чи перетвориться вона виключно
на музей митрополит помісної право
славної церкви України епіфаній
наголосив що підтримує продовження
чернечого життя в Лаврі хоча поки що про
передачу нижньої Лаври в користування
пцу не йдеться Я також засвідчую братії
що всі з вас хто послідують вимогам
канонів томосу відкинуть беззаконну
владу Москви продовжить своє служіння в
Лаврі всі свої можливості та авторитет
ми будемо використовувати для того щоб
захистити вас від залякувань з боку до
теперішнього очільника лаври
натомість в УПЦ яка вважається підлеглою
Московському патріархату переконані що
після виселення ченців лавра пустуватиме
це звернення цей Лебедина пісні єпіфанія
тому що у нього хто ченців немає хто ж
тут буде жити він в нього ж всього очень
сів тут в Лаврі 200 ченців 300 студентів
академії проживає А в нього на всю
Україну 200 ченців і ще й велике питання
що вони насправді є І це треба Хто тут
буде жити це А як ми знаємо природа не
терпить пустоти якщо тут нікого не буде
то тут дуже швидко ростуть і верби і все
інше і все буде в релігійному стані так
само як це на верхній Лаврі священник
пцу Георгій Коваленко наголошує що
монастир ніхто не збирається закривати і
пустувати він не буде давайте спочатку
звільнимо місце а потім реально побачимо
як говорить в приклад да святе місце
пустим не буває і тому це не треба нас
лякати тим що лавра буде пустою вона
наповнюється не монахами Московського
патріархату Тільки вона наповнюється
прочанами вона повністю туристом вони
наповнює за тими людьми які бажають туди
прийти помолитися крім того низка
фахівців і священників нагадують про
історичну традицію монастиря Лаври коли
монахи самі обирали собі архімандрита
історики співробітник києво-печерського
заповідника Костянтин крайній нагадує що
лавра ще з часів заснування була
своєрідним незалежним ні від кого
анклавом Але у 18 столітті після реформ
Катерини II втратила самостійність і
можливість обирати своє керівництво саме
в кінці 18-го століття коли лавра
втрачає свій такий вплив і свої
можливості вона стає просто одним з
монастирів які
із яких Імперія просто свій ідеологічний
вплив розповсюджувало за на каленізовані
Землі на Україну і саме в цей час
по-перше митрополити всі київські лише з
російських губерній от сюди
призначаються і вони водночас стають із
священно-архимандритами Лаври Лаври це
було особливо вразило бо до того вони
постійно протистояли митрополитам а тут
вони просто є вже підпорядковані
водночас нині від імені братії виступає
лише під санкційний Павло Лебідь А
ініціатив про самостійність від
чернецтва поки не надходило зараз
фактично іде боротьба за те щоби надати
суб’єктності оці чернечій громаді самим
монах держава і по цьому охоче щоб
монахи були суб'єктами і мали свою точку
зору свою думку
УПЦ МП на чолі там з антонієм занупрієм
з Павлом вони якраз не хочуть щоб монахи
мали суб'єктність вони хочуть самі
говорити від імені монахів і
вирішувати їхню долю за них і якщо там
вони підуть то щоби всі монахи пішли
священник Георгій Коваленко відзначає
для ченців немає ультиматуму перехід в
пцу або виселення з Лаври він так само
підтримує самовизначення братії з боку
пцу пропозиція до діалогу без
попередніх умов мета діалогу єдність
українського православ'я Це не значить
що хтось кудись має переходити це
значить що давайте вести діалог і
давайте знайдемо формат нашої єдності
без попередніх умов між того сама сам
термін переходу невірний Питання в тому
чи долучаєшся ти до єдності чи в єдності
ти з усім українським православ'ям чи ти
від нього відокремлюєшся поки лавра
залишається у власності держави а саме
києво-печерського за представника хто
проводитьме богослужіння в храмах теж
визначатиме заповідник ця ж структура
платитиме комунальні рахунки Лаври цим
його представники дещо занепокоєні адже
йдеться про мільйонні суми ще одне
питання майбутнє пов’язаної з Росією УПЦ
в Україні у лаврі кажуть експерти церква
втрачає свій головний Актив в Україні
ідеться не лише про духовний вплив а й
про прибутки лавра - це такий великий
бізнес-проект по-перше там є купа різних
послуг від там церковних записок
поминань свічок вони на цьому заробляють
дуже добре тому що лавра це є такий ядро
Тобто ти можеш подати якусь там
поминання в своєму храмі але вважається
що найсильніша молитва в Лаврі тому зі
всієї України і навіть за кордон люди
приїжджають там подають якісь ті Записки
на поминання платять за це гроші купують
інші купують релігійну атрибутику
купують літературу
в Лаврі є готель в Лаврі є там ті трапи
з ніде люди харчуються
власне є великий штат монахів і ченців
які працюють над цих всіх
сфері цього всього обслуговування і
навіть і на будівельних майданчиках там
безкоштовно тобто в тебе є прибуток Але
в тебе немає витрат на зарплатний фонд
водночас як кажуть експерти пов’язана з
Московським патріархатом УПЦ неоднорідна
структура у церкві є й опозиційно
налаштоване духовенство і щирі
прихильники русского мира і ті хто
підлаштовуються під ситуацію за словами
фахівців виселення з Лаври може стати
стимулом до змін у самій Церкві або Ця
церква сприйме як певну допомогу
намагання держави очистити її від
агентів і очиститься сама бо держава за
неї не буде на роботу внутрішньо робити
щодо її
структурування чи те як вона має бути
влаштовувати чи що вона чим вона має
займатися якщо вона не буде робити цього
очищення якщо вона буде чинити спротив
да Українській державі в українському
суспільству но її чекає маргіналізацію в
Онуфрія є така ідея про те що головне -
це
мале стадо але вірне стадо тобто йому не
важливо так кількість вірян вплив як от
вірність і вірність от в таких От
консервативних ультраконсервативних
традиціях і все йде до того що якщо вони
будуть і далі
якби відмовлятися від конструктивних
діалогів що вони перетворяться на таку
ультраконсервативну секту яка там я не
знаю буде
сповідувати
середньовічний спосіб життя І вірити в
якісь дурості от типу того як вони
заперечували існування коронавірусу
також експерти вважають що після історії
з києво-печерської лаврою може постати
питання щодо храмів УПЦ в Чернігові та
Почаєві